the raiders reportedly will release
safety
lamarcus joyner another salary cap
move richie incognito has been or will
be released by the raiders but i want to
go back to 2019 this was a point that
field gates of espn made
on twitter today free agency and trade
editions who got big money in 2019
from the raiders we had joyner four
years 42 million dollars cut after two
years with all of zero interceptions
antonio brown three years 50 million cut
before the season began now i don't
remember the final result of the
grievances but they may not have paid
him very much
if at all of that money given the way
that he behaved and the
the paper trail that they put together
to try to help themselves avoid owing
him money
tyrell williams cut recently four years
44 million he had
two years 42 catches trent brown four
years 66 million signed in 2019
available in trade
some are calling this an indictment of
mike mayok the team's general manager
you don't understand how things work in
las vegas if you think this is mayhawk's
fault mayak's just doing what john
gruden's telling him to do
shireen this all comes back to john
gruden
and if we total it up again i don't know
how much money they actually spent on
these guys
but it's possible they blew the 100
million the same 100 million they're
going to pay him over 10 years
on his wave of free agents in 2019.
yeah it so much reminds me of george
allen and what he used to do with
washington right i mean
he loved those veterans and he would go
out and get those veterans who were on
their last legs
and john green's just like that you look
at what he did in for the oakland
raiders the first time he was there you
look at what he did with the tampa bay
buccaneers when they won the super bowl
yes
it worked that year because tony dungy
and rich mckay had built the talent for
that team the pipeline they had enough
young talent then
but now you look at what he's done with
with these raiders and it's the same
thing they spend money on these free
on these free agents who are very costly
they overspend and they have to go in
and cut them
you build around the draft and they
haven't drafted frankly very well either
they've blown a bunch of those draft
picks so they have to be
better drafting and using their money
more wisely than what they've used it so
far but yes this is firmly on john
gruden this isn't on mike mayok i mean
john gruden is the guy there he's the
voice he's the face
he has total control of that
organization mike
i said this before as it relates to the
packers head coach in gm position and i
think it applies even more pointedly
to john gruden in las vegas and prior to
that during the few years
they were in oakland after he got hired
when you
are the guy and you are going to
continue to be the guy
and your boss is never going to fire you
that takes off the table that that
fear-based motivation
and having that notion that you've got a
chance of being held fully and
completely accountable for your
decisions and the consequences of those
decisions
that causes you to be a lot more careful
about your decisions before you make
them and i really do think
that that that's part of this gruden
knows he's golden in the eyes of mark
davis he ain't firing him
so i make a few mistakes here make a few
mistakes there make some bad decisions
here make some bad decisions there
so what i ain't getting fired you know
it's embarrassing and you get criticized
by people
and look at these numbers look at the
defense my god what have they been doing
with that defense in las vegas but
shireen bottom line is mark davis ain't
gonna fire the guy he can do whatever
the hell he wants and i think
we all need a little bit of that a
little bit of that knowledge
that if we screw up just enough we are
gonna have a job
yeah well he knows he's going to have a
job mike and i
wonder how long they're going to give
him to get this job done because
they're no better right now than when he
got there mike
well i made the point late last year
that anybody else after the three
seasons he had with the raiders
would be on the hot seat we would at
least be talking about the possibility
he's going to be fired and that's just
not on the table and i know that he gets
upset when i say that
oh well it's not like you're getting
fired why are you upset
you're upset that people are noticing
that you've got some sort of unlimited
job security in las vegas you're upset
that we can see what's going on well
that's your problem not mine
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports